so snoop dogg has asked me to bring
tupac back to life for music video so
long story short jesse wellins who's a
friend of ours and snoop dogg are
working on a new music video and they
have an idea and that's to take a
classic clip from the video music awards
from the 90s from mtv where snoop dogg
and tupac are sitting side by side and
they want me to take that clip and make
tupac lip sync to the new song that
snoop is making so not only do i have to
impress one of the most iconic rappers
of all time who is close personal
friends with tupac i also need to stand
up to the awesome coachella hologram
that they did do you know what the
biggest burden of all the highest
pressure that is sitting upon my
shoulders here is i need to impress jake
because jake loves tupac
up as a white suburban kid from
minnesota about 12 years old the first
time i heard tupac i was like whoa
[Music]
holy wow
you can ask anyone i know back then but
i was a
very very big tupac fan growing up back
in the day i would even go on like his
tupac dead forums did all the research
on the conspiracy of whether he was
still alive and obviously through that i
obviously listened to a ton of snoop's
early stuff and actually honestly pox
music back then
actually turned me on to like real world
issues
um and made me think a little bit deeper
about everything that's the real
contribution that he made to me anyway
and i think to many other people
[Music]
we're just like what's just something
that we haven't seen and we're like we
haven't seen tupac do fake and i was
like you guys are the ones that do it
i'm like what's deep fake pock in a
snoop dog music video could break the
internet could do something on the
internet with that little piece alone
i want to introduce you guys to dawg
this is quarterback digital they're the
guys that are going to be doing the joke
gonna get we'll come back let's see how
the sausage is made yeah
[Music]
you provided that one yeah yeah
that's gangster [__] right there
i was thinking we could do it again if
you had like a back wood and some really
good like some green ass wheat or
something some really good weed oh it's
good i mean like yeah that looks good
that looked good for the camera because
then we could like basically get it
right through it pull out and then
you're like twisting it got you yeah go
get it okay
[Music]
yeah that's [__] great
what i've learned from working with soup
is he's super humble really nice guy
easy to work with as long as he's like
into the project and his and his time is
like being used effectively
don't smoke pie on set like that's not
good it's hard as much as you want to
he's got weed everywhere and you're like
because last music video i learned the
whole crew thought it was okay to smoke
weed because smooth smoke weed so
the video the last shot was just like a
mess
everyone was like girl like i don't know
what to do and we're just like oh my god
so don't smoke pot even though snoop's
smoking it tupac and what you do with
him there's such a legacy left in the
music world based upon what you guys did
then and now and i just i wanted to ask
you personally like what did you learn
from a figure like that being friends
with him and what can people take away
into their own lives from what he did
and how he lived i think what i learned
from tupac was basically a different
kind of work ethic always had a good
work ethic about myself as far as being
timely and being on point and being a
professional but he just showed me how
to be a little bit more faster at it as
far as like getting to the to the meat
of the dog and not really just listening
to it all the time and not absorbing it
but more or less just doing it and keep
doing it and doing it and then let the
engineers mix it and master it and not
fall in love with it but fall in love
with the craft of being able to do it
and continue to do it so
i feel like that was something that was
passed on to me and now i'm showing it
through my work ethic as far as the
different things that i do and the way i
diversify myself and it passes that on
to the young generation to show them
that you can do the same thing and i'm
doing because that's an old man if i'm
doing it you as a young man you got
three steps to go ahead and beat me at
it so go ahead and get to it and do it
appreciate that no thank you
and now i have to do a deep fake of
tupac for snoop dogg
i need to still pull this off i still
need to bring tupac back to life and not
just in a blurry deep fake but it needs
to look good so here's my plan i'm going
to use the old model that i used for a
keanu reeves video i'll be using that
model from deepface lab here because i
already have a ton of time put into it i
like a week of gpu time put into it i'm
just training random faces basically i
can take that hopefully quickly turn
around in a couple days this deep take a
tupac all right so here's the clip it's
hard to find high quality versions of
this which is challenge number one right
trying to find high quality video from
1996. so for me to do a good job of this
i need to rely on what we know we
pioneered some things with our tom
cruise deep fake that no one had done
with dpx before we had an impersonator
come in he had the mannerisms he had the
voice in this case i don't have to worry
about the voice but i need to worry
about everything else so we have a
friend his name is josh haraway and he
is a professional tupac impersonator
check it out this is not tupac this is
josh
looking a lot like tupac funny once he
like takes all his stuff off he doesn't
look like tupac at all but when he's in
costume and playing the character it's
spot-on you know it's the mannerisms
it's the attitude it's how you kind of
carry yourself on on camera
i worked on the tupac uh 2012 coachella
hologram with dr dre i was a highlight
that was that was fun times and it's a
pretty interesting technology because
the computer's learning how to encode a
face just like how a jpeg is how you
encode a picture or an mp3 is how to
encode an audio file you basically have
a face encoder and a face decoder and
you're just running one face data set
through a different face decoder so
basically paints that face with the
features of a different face so i see a
government contract in the future so
yeah i think we can do this for sure man
i'm going to need to record josh in full
costume matching this costume in a
lighting setup that matches this sliding
setup on a green screen you're going to
need to erase tupac from this shot and
replace him with josh and josh is going
to be giving us the performance lip
syncing to the music and then i need to
deep fake tupac's face onto josh we're
actually super super lucky because a the
camera is locked off and b snoop is
probably very very high in sitting still
and not moving i can isolate tupac
really easily here i mean there's a
little bit of shadow stuff on his arm
snoop is zoned hard right there clint on
a scale of one to ten and how high do
you think he is in this picture probably
like a six
dude i don't think he's ever smoked in
his life nico what do you think he'll be
done i have one week to do it you have
to work extra fast when you're working
for snoop dogg because he measures
everything in dog ears yo this is tupac
shakur and if you want to see more
interviews with some of the greatest
musicians of all time like myself
subscribe to corridor crew twister
twitters can somebody explain to me what
tic toc is
i need to train the encoding and
decoding part of this to make it work
and the more time i spend training the
better it looks but to do any of the
training at all i need pictures i need
pictures of these faces i need lots and
lots of pictures of tupac in every
single lighting situation every single
expression every single angle you know
what the biggest issue is everything
filmed in the 90s has interlacing look
at that interlacing there's a captain
disillusion video on interlacing if you
want to learn more about it but your
image files in your video have these
little lines of everything if there's
motion which you can see right here i
found
three videos that were high quality
enough that might work i have this
interview here decently high quality not
interlaced this interview which is the
best quality i found and then finally we
have this music video which has
interlacing but i just have to go
through and manually cut out all the
interlaced frames but i have another
gigantic problem everybody for some
reason decided to film tupac from the
same side they have to film from the
nose ring size so i don't have data for
the other side of his face so i have to
go into premiere after effects flip all
my footage and re-export it again so now
all these same shots just flipped all
right so yesterday we had josh come in
and we filmed with him and it went great
great performer jake did a great job
being a costume designer we matched the
lighting pretty well i think green
screen looks good so i've gone through
and i've extracted all of his faces so
these are all his poses here and with
those i was able to run the deep fake
training it's gone for 24 hours now so
i'm encoding with josh's face and then
taking the data and decoding with two
fog space
and here's what i got
it's getting there it's getting there
it's blurry but you know the biggest
thing is it's flickering it's flickering
all over the place as it moves it's
going bright and dark and like changing
weirdly the reason that's happening is
because i only have like three sources
for tupac the lighting situation's
almost the same between them it's only
seeing his face under like three
lighting conditions it doesn't know how
to draw the face when the lighting
situation is different here's the extra
funny thing look at his teeth he has one
central tooth that's what teeth on his
side his face is perfectly symmetrical
his eyes are really symmetrical his
eyebrows are perfectly symmetrical it's
because i [__] i only have dude tooth
pockets
so now that you pointed out i can't see
anything other the fact he's got one
middleton
you can't really tell if i spend more
time training it it will get a little
bit better the biggest issue right now
is the skin is flickering it's actually
pretty easy to deal with all you need to
do is enable a mode in the deep fake
training that randomly shifts the colors
of the image because then you get some
images that are bright some are dark
some are tinted orange slides to the
green you know whatever gives you a
little bit of everything so the program
learns how to deal with the face under
any kind of color condition and
therefore it can give you a
non-flickering result so i just need to
go and enable that and train it for
probably another 24 hours and i'll
probably be fine it's ridiculous i am
currently working on trying to figure
out how to attach a nerf gun to a racing
drone and have it fire remotely i think
it's going to be amazing it's a very
very challenging build documenting the
whole thing uh stay tuned uh sorry not
to cut you off i have a problem um no
joy it's kind of frustrating i thought
you got some variety in there yeah i
thought i had variety in there too but
apparently random color transfer just
means tint everything green and only
green
here so on the left here this is the
picture that's being fed into the
encoding and it's mostly randomly tinted
and now it's just green it's only more
than one color random means other colors
like i don't know pick one blue
i spent a good chunk of time trying to
fix this like i reinstalled the program
i changed all my graphics drivers i
tried swapping to different models and
it's just stuck
being green
that doesn't look very good
well the flickering's gone
even though the program's not working i
can do this manually i'm going to set up
an after effects composition i'm going
to take all the frames both the mirrored
and the unmirred and i'm going to apply
a wiggle operator to a color balance
filter every single value in the color
balance is going to be wiggled per frame
wiggle is an after effects way of
changing a value with noise basically
every 30th of a second is going to
change the amount randomly 80 values in
either direction from where the value is
once for each frame it's going to have a
completely new set of values and i've
copied and pasted this into every single
color balance entry here so if i preview
this
it's just like a party going on
alright so i'm going to manually export
new pictures with wiggled color and
wiggled brightness and then i'm going to
use those to train this and that should
theoretically fix the issue
snoop dogg i don't think he gets angry i
think if he were to see this and it
wasn't very good i feel like he'd sit in
the corner
and get kind of quiet and feel kind of
sad and then his producer found him back
hey snoop you want to record this track
and he's like
not feeling its
day and i don't want that to happen
[Music]
all right so i'm finished i think i'm
done
no one's actually seen it yet done with
the whole shot i'm done with the whole
shot i've made it look like it was
filmed in the 90s i've made it look like
it was tupac i'm ready to show it to
people i hope they like it hey jake do
you want to see
tupac the resurrection does anybody else
want to see the resurrection here we go
no one's seen this yet so you're
bringing like tupac back to life here we
go every time i see you you beg a [__]
for money don't even ask how i'm doing
but tell me keep it 100 so i'ma say it
and mean it so you can hear this loud
and clear [__] outta here
there it is
that's crazy is it weird bringing
something back from the dead with the
deep pick
has it ever been done they've already
made them into a hologram yeah
this is an honest this is an honest
rendering yes yeah it was render with
love yeah i guess the next step is to
show jesse and snoop and see
see what snoop thinks i'm here with the
dog
we about to watch he's about to see it
for first time you didn't see nothing
yet right i see a number i seen a
dinosaur let's go all reactions all
real [__]
[Music]
i know you got to watch it like four
times and get it off [__]
extraordinary
very very quite contrary
that [__] is going to be
legendary that's hard that tupac is
crazy right
that's hard
all that [__] was hard i was liking all
of that
my [__] was right like the right spirit
to write everything on it to write
everything on it guess he likes it i
hope he likes it i like it i love it the
final shot is delivered and the music
video is coming out any day now so head
on over to steve's channel and watch it
um it might even be out right now so
we'll put the link in the description
when the video is live and make sure you
subscribe for more deep fake experiments
on the corridor crew channel